hi my name is jake i don't have any  any particular like expertise  in anything but  the revenant  [Music]  yeah yeah if if um if that happened  to me i would be oof  yeah 127 hours  you know this is a good example of how  to  survive in one of those caves  canyon things if something's really  really stuck  somewhere you know you could cut it off  because you're protecting like the  important  right like the importance in things on  your  on your body so  gravity  in space nobody can hear you scream  but if you're connected to like a radio  antenna  uh with your other astronauts  then they'll hear they'll hear you  scream  that's my take on these again i'm not  like an expert  or anything so that's like